ils ont tous 20 pour la plupart ils ont
voulu faire du disney rester jusqu'à la
fin de cette séquence car la dernière
personne qui va arriver
elle m'a fait beaucoup de peine mais
elle a quelque chose
on commence avec maxime gagné qui va
mettre le saut avec une chanson du livre
de la jungle
[Applaudissements]
j'ai perdu en fait c'est là c'est le
déguisement le plus tenace du monde en
fait j'ai chaud qui s'est tenue ce que
vous direz à bas coût de location
je vous laisse le micro merci merci et
prenait le micro merci léché reach merci
mon chéri voilà merci donc il faut
passer par la bei passe par la passe par
là tu peux donner c'est pas la peine que
tu fasses ton tour passe par là tant des
marchés
[Rires]
à tort on a une blanche neige qui est là
elle est avec nous je vous demande
d'accueillir à gâteau proulx sais pas
[Applaudissements]
un jour mon prince
l'andra 1
un jour et seule
un château
[Musique]
alors qui
oh
merci blanche neige
je retravaille les poulets voulurent son
v12 benjamin castaldi et m'a dit entre
mulan et blanche neige entre mulsanne et
blanche neige c'est vrai on dirait
blanche mullan merci merci merci merci à
vous merci à bientôt pour quitter numéro
2 on a je vous dis la vérité
ça va aller comme ça je dois vous dire
des choses on enchaîne avec un duo qui
va vous interpréter ce rêve bleu
je vous demande d'accueillir yasmine v
novelli kelly et aladdin le aladin du
pauvre à la demande au maire
ce voyage en blé ainsi au pays du rêve
le bleu ce rêve
c'est un nouveau monde en couleurs où
personne ne nous dit c'est être interdit
de croire encore au bonheur
[Musique]
je ne les crois pas démérité par l'état
onze de rêve
vous
[Musique]
merci merci merci kelly l'aï jamais
merci les séries c'est mieux que je
pensais ya rokhaya diallo qui m'a envoyé
un sms qui me dit muskin le bal ou de
maxime gainey l'a pas manger c'est vrai
que c'était aller les chéris
on a maintenant oui je vous avais dit
que ça des stores c'est isabelle a dit
isabelle et gilles qui vont nous
transporter au pays de mary poppins
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas mal ça moi comme centre bravo
mecheri alesi jules et isabelle vous
bottez eux
je vous le dis on a encore deux artistes
un plus une surprise
on va aller on va finir enfin presque
finir avec s'il vous dit que l'hiver
s'installe doucement dans la nuit vous
me dites que la reine des neiges et
l'arrêt est bien la reine des neiges un
coup de pelle c'est pas un coup de pelle
qu'elle a pris là c'est toute la
pelleteuse elle a pris la dameuse on l'a
vu la gueule
donner de plus à mon avis il était en
train de donner les pistes et la bimbo a
girl
vous allez voir on a une reine des
neiges ça va être très court mais métro
le but c est trop court mais trop long
merci vous démarrez de ses biens hélas
hélas tout ce que vous avez là là là ça
me va très bien merci
l'aiglon la reine des neiges
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pastour royaume de solitude
ma place car pour toujours
[Musique]
moi par ce biais de man autres lors
d'enchères organisées en vain
[Applaudissements]